decades ago the term artificial
intelligence was just another
frankenstein story but today it could be
a citizen in your next door
right from its genesis artificial
intelligence was programmed to probe
into human life and eliminate the
fortifications of the impossibilities in
many areas like healthcare
transportation communication and much
more
there are hundreds and thousands of
organizations tech communities and
engineers worldwide working round the
clock to make miracles a reality
and today we are going to discuss the
top 10 amongst those who are
contributing a significant part
so here we are the top 10 artificial
intelligence companies to watch in 2022.
at number 10 we have this ai
this ai is a revolutionary approach to
dramatically improvise the way
healthcare is delivered
with ai focuses on implementing
artificial intelligence to diagnose and
detect abnormalities in the human body
via ct cta mri x-ray ekg ultrasound etc
this ai coordinates both the patient and
healthcare professionals at the same
time
the patient reports are shared via
mobile to all the concerned medical
teams results are astonishing with
vis-a-i there is a significant
improvement in productivity and
reduction of time required for patient
treatment and discharge
this ai was founded in 2016 and
established in november 2021.
the company runs with 223 employees and
the headquarters is in san francisco
this ai mainly focuses on improving and
filling all the gaps between patients
and healthcare professionals
this ai offers handsome salaries to its
employees
in india the salaries range from 4 lakhs
to 18 lakhs per annum and in america the
wages range from 110 000
to 210 000 per annum so at number nine
we have farm wise
ten years ago an automated wheat killing
robo was science fiction
now its rise of practical weed killing
robots with millimeter precision thanks
to farmwise the first product of the
californian-based company was an
automated robo-weeder based on ai
computer vision and also robotics
the robot would eliminate weeds from the
vegetable fields
farmvise intends to build innovative
systems and efficient procedures that
help farmers streamline farming with
efficiency
farmwise was established in the year
2020 the company functions with 50
employees on board and actively looking
for expansion
the company follows the procedure of
paying farming equipment employees and
contract personnel hourly
farm buys makes an annual turnover of
8.5 million us dollars
on average an aiml engineer at farm wise
earns anywhere around
113 000 per annum
up next we have amp robotics at number
eight we have amp robotics while others
are busy trying to revolutionize mankind
with ai amp robotics came up with an
innovative idea that happens to be a
kind gesture of gratitude towards nature
amp ai designed an artificial
intelligence robo that recycles e-waste
plastic waste and waste from
construction sites and much more the
robo precisely identifies paper plastics
and metals by learning and recognizing
them via color size shape and a few more
factors
the colorado based company is currently
operational with 137 employees in total
and looking forward to expand the idea
globally erp robotics aims to
reimagining recycling and to create a
world without waste through artificial
intelligence
amp robotics pays handsome salaries to
their employees with an average salary
of an employee amp
robotics varies between ninety six
thousand dollars to one thirty one
thousand dollars per annum
coming up next is a giant at number
seven we have automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a global robotics
automation and software company founded
in the year 2003. the company's
headquarters is located in san jose
california
the global rpa leader offers cloud
native web-based intelligent automation
solutions to the world's leading cloud
companies
automation anywhere's automation 360
offers a variety of intelligent tools
and self-learning systems to automate
every redundant task
automation anywhere is focusing on
transforming the companies to be rpa
oriented and the current covet
situations have triggered the need for
automation even more
a recent survey states the rpe adoption
rates will increase by 57
in just one more year
the globally recognized multinational
company works with more than 2
200 plus employees on board
the company pays decent salaries as well
at number six we have microsoft ai
microsoft integrated ai into cloud
computing microsoft's ai platform
provides robust solutions to cloud
related problems microsoft's ai division
is headquartered in redmond washington
with around 5000 employees specifically
in the ai division and aims to train and
certify 15 000 employees by 2022.
microsoft ai is a robust framework
designed for developing ai solutions
using machine learning data science
robotics iot and more
ai enable services accelerate
productivity to a greater level
microsoft azure uses ai to get best of
breed infrastructure with enterprise
create security availability compliance
and manageability microsoft also pays
handsome salaries to their employees the
average salary of an employee at the
microsoft ai division earns up to 160
thousand dollars per annum
at number five we have data robo
data robo has its headquarters in boston
it is one of the ai cloud leaders
providing a unified platform to its
cloud users to accelerate the delivery
of ai to the cloud
data robo aims to understand and
leverage the inherent capabilities of
the platform
data robo has the caliber to help
business analysts in building predictive
analytics with no knowledge of machine
learning
it uses automated ml to build and deploy
accurate predictive models in a short
span of time
the global cloud leader currently
operates with more than a thousand
employees worldwide
data robo compensates its employees with
handsome salaries an average employee at
data robo earns up to 160 000 per year
and up to 3 lakh 400 000 rupees in india
at number 4 we have amazon the alexa
maker amazon is one of the tech giants
interested in adopting ai into its
various divisions
amazon calls its ai services amazon lex
amazon poly amazon recognition and
amazon machine learning
these services are accessible through a
software api call or console the amazon
ai suite of services can have text or
voice conversations with an end user
using a conversational chat ops
interface
the seattle-based tech giant is
currently using ai for its smart home
solutions
ai companies like alexa and its business
intelligence needs amazon is also
conducting trials on drone delivery to
save time and efforts to deliver goods
and services to remote locations with
ease
amazon ai aims to provide biometric
payments to its customers at cash-free
stores
the approach is still in trials
amazon calls it just walk out technology
amazon has enormous teams and pays
decent salaries to its employees for
example an employee at amazon can earn
up to 20 lakh rupees per annum in india
and about a hundred thousand dollars per
annum in united states of america
at number three we have data bricks
databricks is one of the best data
driven companies
data bricks lake houses combine data
warehouses reliability performance and
governance with the openness and
flexibility of data lakes
data brick is headquartered in san
francisco california and has 15 office
locations across 11 countries
the company announces plans on
delivering keynote on data and machine
learning product innovations and the
rise of the lake house architecture
advancements
databricks currently operates with 2000
plus employees globally
the organization compensates its
employees with handsome salaries an
average employee at databricks makes
about 154 000 us dollars and around 2.1
lakh rupees per annum in india
next we have meta at number two we have
meta
meta formerly known as facebook is
innovating in advanced way of social
interaction
meta has integrated artificial
intelligence and it's being called the
meta ai
meta-ai has its headquarters in toronto
canada
meta-ai has redesigned a new material
and touch sensor with potential to boost
the development of metawars
a team of researchers at the metawars
have worked jointly with scientists at
carnegie mellon university to build
reskin a plastic three millimeter thick
membrane with magnetic particles capable
of measuring touch and sensation
a thrilling experiment meta has under
its sleeve i would say meta currently
operates remotely with about 350
employees on board
critiques also state that meta pays a
vast salary to its ai experts with an
average salary of 1 lakh 750 000
paid to the employees at meta ai
at number one we have google ai
google ai is the division of google
dedicated to artificial intelligence
ceo sundar pichai announced it at google
i o 2017. google ai has its headquarters
in california
google ai is demonstrating its quantum
computing supremacy with its new and
powerful cinema processor google's ai is
one of the most widespread technologies
it's almost everywhere
from your language translations to
helping people with speech impairments
to have a successful conversation
social media interactions shopping lists
and assisting users with gps sending
alerts to its users about natural
calamities and saving them
google ai has announced that its
research team is designing next
generation ai chips for a smart future
in addition a new ai model allows
artificial intelligence to perform chip
design that more efficiently solves
unique aspects of any problem with an
artificial neural network
google ai currently works with our four
divisions with massive teams we have
come to an end of this session on the
top 10 ai companies to watch out for in
2022
we hope this session was exciting and
informative please feel free to leave us
your feedback in the comment section
below
a quick subscription to our channel and
a like would be appreciated
thanks and until next time stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here